joooeeeeyyyy all right we just got back
from seeing steep Ubisoft's like sort of
forgotten about extreme sports game they
just announce it at e3 this past year
about six months ago we haven't actually
heard much about it since then but we
finally got a chance to go play actually
if the GoPro Offices of all places had
about three or four hours of hands-on
time and got to see a lot of the
open-world stuff I'm kind of excited
about this one if for no other reason
than we haven't really had a great
extreme sports game in a while like
skate three is the last one that comes
to mind and that came out like six years
ago and this year's been dominated by
shooters so I'm kind of excited just to
have a game where you can like jump off
the mountains and do tricks and stuff
that said you know we did seal out of
the game yesterday but let's let's start
with the positives coming away from
yesterday's demo what did you like about
it what did you like about what we got
to play okay so coming out demo I think
the biggest takeaway that I was able to
get from it was the sense of scale for
the game um so the game is billed as an
open-world extreme sports type game
where you can snowboard you can ski you
can you know wingsuit yeah wingsuit you
can write a parachute down the mountain
yeah paragliding and what it does really
well I think is that it gives the player
a sense of like a really good sense of
scale the game is a recreation of the
the Alps actually and so when you're
when you're writing down those mountains
it really does feel like you're this
tiny human in these with these gigantic
mountains around you it just makes it
makes you feel small yeah I think that
sense of scale and like the overwhelming
sense of like you're in part of this
bigger world and there is so much to go
and explore I absolutely agree like I
love the overall aspect of it you know
in a weird way it reminded me of
wandering around in Skyrim and just
seeing like a little icon on your
mini-map Amman oh and what that is and
just wanting to make it over the next
hill to see what the next thing was this
game has that same thing where hey there
might be a halfpipe over the next hill
or hey you might find a new like a
glacier run or something I love that
sense of discovery and I like that you
can play the game just by kind of like
exploring the world and doing whatever
you want you don't you don't necessarily
have to go from event to event you can
kind of just have fun in this big giant
world many other big points I will say
going back to the wingsuits yeah out of
all of the sports that they have in that
game I think that's most exhilarating
probably the most exciting thing I've
played in a long time yeah
so one of the one of the races that they
have is that you have to fly on the
wingsuit down the mountain and you score
points by being as close to the the
ground as possible right and like
ducking between like narrow openings and
stuff that's a risky maneuver every time
you're trying to get as close to the
ground trying to almost skid across the
snow sometimes and dodging the cliffs
and hopefully making it down in one
piece yeah that was super fun
III agree actually I think that the
wingsuit stuff was my favorite as well a
great sense of speed great sense of risk
like it's really cool just like soaring
through these narrow openings and being
able to compete with your friends I mean
that I think was the most direct
competition that we saw you can kind of
link up with people and just kind of
experience the world with them but
you're not necessarily competing
directly that was the closest we really
came yeah um I will say that some of the
other sports didn't grab me quite as
much none of them were bad but but we're
certainly shaky er I will say that like
paragliding stuff was kind of boring
especially compared to the wingsuit I
mean the wingsuit you're speeding down
the mountain paragliding it's you're
kind of just floating and maneuvering
and I still really get it it's like
super clunky I think yeah of all of them
that's probably since it is the slowest
you also have probably the least control
out of all of them and it doesn't the
game doesn't do a very good job at
telling you exactly how to control it in
the first place
yeah I'm so a lot of times when I was
controlling I was kind of just rocking
back and forth I saw people in the the
trailers do flips with the parachute and
I couldn't figure out how to do that for
the first like 15 minutes
yeah I agree I mean actually a lot of my
biggest problems with the demo that we
played had very little to do with
gameplay and much more to do with the
presentation like I really hated the
menu system or even just navigating the
world map every menu for whatever reason
you have a little cursor that you just
buy painfully slowly guide around the
screen to select stuff it's like really
cumbersome and unintuitive and every
menu uses that same system it's very
obnoxious and it's most cumbersome when
it comes to the world map you have to
like look for little icons on this giant
map and you don't even necessarily know
what they mean and you're trying to zoom
in on them like and I actually asked the
developers is there a list is there a
list of events like if I just want to
jump into a trick event on a snowboard
can I just jump to that immediately and
they're like oh that's not it's not in
the game and hey maybe it'll add that
but currently just trying to navigate
how things work
a pain in the ass and actually I had the
same experience with the replay system I
really like that they've actually
focused on creating and sharing videos
with your friends skate did the same
thing and I think that works really well
for this type of game that's based on
like finding lines and doing tricks and
things like that so I love that that's
part of the game but there are certain
things about the way the replay system
works that I didn't really connect with
you can't hide the UI you don't have
like a timeline bar that you can scrub
through you just have to watch and
reward rewind and fast-forward in real
time like on the screen in front of you
it could have been a little bit more
robust I think yeah I think a lot of the
problems come from like just very small
things like it the game I feel overall
lacks a little bit of Polish yeah
especially when it comes to the menu and
UI well they still have a month before
the official release the game is due out
on December second so that's not a lot
of time to polish things up but it's
possible they were able to smooth some
of these rough edges I mean again a lot
of the things that we're talking about
aren't major overhaul changes right it's
stuff like the UI things that are
relatively easy to fix so hopefully
they'll take this next month to make
some of those changes in some of those
additions prior to release though there
is an open beta on November 18th to 21st
and an early access beta November 10th
to the 14th if you want to go to Ubisoft
and sign up so people will have a chance
to play the game before it's full
released a month from now so hey we'll
see how that pans out hopefully they'll
get some information from those betas
hopefully they make some of the changes
we've talked about and when the game
actually comes out on December 2nd it'll
just be awesome so Joey any closing
thoughts
I'm really hoping it'll be awesome you
know it's been a long time like you said
since we've had a like a proper
snowboarding or even extreme sports game
yeah so I'm excited for it yeah I'm
hoping man I'm like I'm primed to love
this game I just hope we can deliver so
for more on steep and coverage of the
beta and everything extreme sports stay
tuned to came spot calm